hey everybody welcome back the planet
coaster in this video I'll work on just
one building F which is kind of
underwhelming for a video of 15 minutes
which does equal 3 hours of gameplay I
have that cleared up again because I
still do get some comments about it but
yeah I took 3 hours to record this and I
still got only one building done which
is a little bit different than usual
usually I don't really like to record
tweaking with buildings and I like to
have some sort of plan when I get into a
building that doesn't really require
much of tweaking and can do it as
quickly as possible but with this
building I wanted to keep a lot of time
and space left to tweak it and make sure
that it was exactly the way I want to
because it's a really important building
and it's somewhat large as well and has
some areas of scenery around it too it's
basically going to be a restaurants a
pretty large restaurant at that and as
such it's going to be the weenie of this
area basically the park so far it
doesn't really have too many weenies
but this plaza doesn't really have
anything that really catches your
attention so far and this building is
really going to make or break the look
of the plaza itself and because of that
it's a pretty important building and I
wanted to make sure that I got it right
exactly the way I want to so um yeah
here it goes - trying that's the the
restaurant itself is actually not that
it's not that unique or anything it's a
pretty standard kind of restaurant not
really going out of the box or anything
like that it's just one part of the
building with the gable roof and then
other parts which is slightly larger and
is tilted 90 degrees on the end to kind
of give it up front and make it sort of
look as if it's really pointing toward
the plaza itself but that's basically
everything to the building itself so I'm
gonna have any towers or any shapes that
go into all sorts of directions it is
going to be a somewhat simple building
in terms of shape but I do want to get
in quite a bit of detailing and trying
some new things and one of the first
things that I really really needed to
try something new over and also probably
fixed throughout the park is the corner
stones actually got quite a few messages
from different
what about the cornerstones which in the
rest of the park not all the
cornerstones are rights in that belongs
the long side in the short side of the
cornerstones aren't always placed
correctly in the buildings which is
something that I do in a fix in the
future but at least I am managed to get
them in right on this building so that's
quite an achievement and also I wanted
to try some new cornerstones some more
light ones many of the buildings that I
have so far in the park are very heavy
on the wood and this building I wanted
to make it a little bit more fancy with
more stone details things like that and
you see it coming back in the windows as
well it's some more there are more
lights tones in general on this building
than on the rest of the parks buildings
because they have more wood in them and
just more darker colors in general and
this comes back in the windows as well
which have much more white accents than
a lot of the wooden elements that the
rest of the windows in the park have and
what I also wanted to do with these
Windows is and in quite a lot of
different pieces to make the details for
it not because I want to make very
detailed windows I do want to keep them
quite simple but to just give them a
look that the other windows don't really
have especially with like a very limited
array of items as we have at the in the
game at the moment it's really easy to
sort of run into the issue where
everything looks more or less the same
because no matter how like many
different shapes and structures you make
if they're made out of the same basic
elements you kind of start recognizing
those and seeing the same windows and
all the exact buildings seeing the exact
same windows in all of the buildings it
is kind of a thing that puts you out of
whatever immersion you're really in and
I love this book these windows to look
quite simple and quite a bit different
from all of the windows that you see in
the game itself and also from the
windows that I had in the park so far so
that's why I wanted to stack all of
those different details but at the same
time still keep it quite Square and
simple the top of the building though is
quite similar to many of the buildings
that I have so far wanted to get some
stucco in there just to have it relate a
bit more to the theme because I didn't
want the building to stick out too much
and the same goes for this more Bank
parts
of the building which doesn't come out
as much as the front does and it was
quite a bit lower so it's definitely not
going to be the most in attention
drawing part of the building but it died
it does give it a pretty nice shape and
a nice connection and also a very good
way to actually add an entrance to the
building and make sure that it could
realistically actually be a restaurants
one thing to note is that this also
won't actually be a functional
restaurant I try to keep as many things
functional as I can but in this case I
really can't hide any kind of chief beef
inside of this building because I would
inside of this building because I would
have to get a stall inside of it and
have a part actually go to audits which
is practically not really possible with
the setup that I'm making here which
you'll see in a bit so it's not going to
be a functional restaurant or just
pretty much make believe now I just
wanted to quickly make this simple porch
here to make it a bit more interesting
to look at and also make the building
look a bit more like it's an actual
restaurant and underneath that porch
which is sort of hanging over the patio
which I built I wanted to get this same
wooden wall which I used for the station
of the coaster earlier on just because I
didn't have enough lag in the game yet
and I definitely needed hundreds of
windows to make one simple wooden wall
or a stone wall I should say but I do
really like this war it's might be like
a very minor touch but I wanted to avoid
using the brick walls because well the
floor is already made out of that bricks
x2 and all of the other textures are
already quite common and this does give
it like a different color for the
foundation than for the rest of the
building which does look a little bit
nicer I think and a pretty good way to
get started on the scenery around the
building itself because the building at
this point is pretty much finished and
the rest of this video is going to be
mostly about its how to actually
incorporate the building into the area
around it now what I wanted to do is
actually get some pretty good
connections for the patio with paths
around this area because obviously it is
quite a sizable restaurant but I can't
actually directly connect it to the path
in front of it because it's a pretty
large height difference
so I wanted to get some stares in on
both sides of the of the restaurants and
first I thought I might actually add
some wooden stairs but though is just
ended up looking very poor and very
ghetto ish so that didn't really work
out in the end
and figured it would be nicer to
actually have some stone stairs which
fit in with the look of the terrace
itself and have some nicer looking
fences on the sides of that as well so
that's what I'm trying to figure out
here it took quite a while to actually
get these pieces together but I like
with like every single fence that I try
to build and every single border
alongside parts I like to try and mess
with some slightly different looks to it
some slightly different textures and
pieces and overall shape just to make
sure that you know not everything starts
looking the same I think one of the
easiest mistakes that isn't even saving
a lot of time or making things a lot
easier is to just use the same fences
all around the park to just copy one
fence all over the park or copy the same
kind of lanterns all over the park that
kind of path elements which are really
easy and quick to make but can really
make or break how a certain area looks
just for that I wanted to get some
slightly different fences in for all of
these different parts of this area just
to get some variation into the fences as
well otherwise everything just becomes
surrounded by their same looking fences
which is a bit boring to look at now one
other thing that I wanted to do here is
something that I've been wanting to try
for quite a while and looking back I'm
still not sure if this was the best
decision to build over here but I've
been wanting to make threal assist for
quite a long time I just didn't really
find the right place for it and I've
been planning to build a trellis on this
spot here although looking back it is
quite a tight spot as you can see and
it's kind of bit smaller than it looks
when I drew it out on paper so I'm not
really sure how well this worked out in
the end but I did have a dead corner or
over here more or less
and not really a big fan of leaving some
kind of corner of a theme park
completely empty and leaving it as a
place where you can't really do anything
so wanted to build the trellis here and
actually be able to have some tables and
chairs underneath it in the future just
as an extension of the restaurant itself
and actually incorporate this earlier
into it as well because it's not enough
place to really place another store in
or another Midway game or anything like
that and building a quick trellis to at
least get some connection with the
restaurant seems like all the best idea
on this very tight space here it's quite
an easy thing to build as well just a
few wooden posts and some of the drift
wood planks and in between that's for
the trellises themselves some letters
and filling it up with a bit of
shrubbery on the top which is quite
handy since it is very flat and you can
very easily use that shrub to make vines
or whatever you really want to make and
incorporate it into buildings so figured
it would be nice to have that on top of
it as well and that basically finishes
off the basic trellis and here I'm just
messing with the park border a bit which
is something that I've been wanting to
do as well though I won't feature much
of it in time lapses I do want to get
like some slight differences in the park
border in so far it's 100% all the exact
same fence which I just copy and pasted
it round but I do wanna have some
different fences and different openings
and things in the park border as well
even though it's not part of the park it
does kind of contribute to the way that
the park looks especially looking from
like an aerial perspective so I want to
mess with that a bit in the future as
well now for what's quite important for
this being the restaurants and tables
and chairs these are pretty much the
tables and chairs that I took from El
Fame except
now I think that's pretty much it just
some very slight changes on the chairs
mostly and that's basically it the exact
same design I will also get some
umbrellas or parasols on top of tables
and other restaurants but since this
already had the porch and the trellis as
well I won't really be messing with too
many parasols over the tables in this
case but even with all that decoration
I thought the building was still looking
a little bit boring so I actually took
my big buddy the number one help against
boring roofs the dormer in Medic wick
dormer just one because I didn't want to
make too many and one dormer
I thought would pretty much do to make
that thing on the side of the roof a
little less boring actually decided to
copy it over to the other side with
building as well so you'll see that
happening sometime soon but it's quite a
simple dormer anyway to almost don't
really have to be anything too special
just a window with a little bit of
decoration around it and the roof but I
was quite picky about how large it would
be one of it to be well slightly lower
than the top of the roof obviously but
also stick out quite a bit and be quite
close to the bottom of the roof as well
so ended up going with this height and
sticking it a little deeper inside the
roof on the other side which made it
look like a completely different dormer
actually to finish off the roof and one
last touch that I wanted to add to not
just well get rid of this very boring
section of the roof but also give this
building a little bit of a more rustic
feel to it is and a large chimney which
is actually sort of burrowing its way
into a window on the side there I might
want to actually look into that but um
it's quite as simple chimney I chose to
use the brick pieces in the end because
even though they aren't really the most
usual pieces or the best-looking pieces
to build a chimney out of they are very
different from the textures that are
used on the building's so far and I
wanted to get a sort of dark chimney in
just became a little bit of a struggle
here at getting these windows in but
and it's not that hard to get them in as
long as you're just placing money the
only issue is that it might contribute
to the lag which I'll get at some point
in the future but yeah that's the pretty
simple chimney quite large and I wanted
to stick on the side of the wall so you
can really have a fire almost in the in
the middle of the building and
restaurants on the side of the wall as
well which will it should be quite nice
figuring if there were actually
interiors in this restaurant it's
something which does add to the general
charming atmosphere now something that I
was messing with for quite a long time
here it's getting the chair the stairs
in the front here because I wanted to
get some stairs here since I had just
enough space to connect at this pass
here with the path in front of it and
the only issue that I had for quite a
while is figuring out the exact
steepness that I had to have tequila
connected and this is eventually what I
ended up with just a very very simple
staircase made out of just a couple of
pieces actually run a few tries there
with all sorts of different pieces and
differents details and materials but in
the end the most simple option just to
now to fit best I think so I went with
that and the rest of the decoration is
quite simple just to tie it in to what
the rest of the park basically looks
like a bit of rock work to blend in the
foundation of the building a bit more
with the area around it and a very small
border alongside the path to get rid of
that sort of repetitive looking border
that the parts have by default and some
shrubbery to basically finish it off and
top of all of the rock work kind of like
a nice cherry on top of a pie basically
and on the back of the restaurants I
wanted to have some pretty dense foliage
a lot of trees in here for a couple of
reasons for one I really wanted to make
this house look like it's you know a
house in the middle of the forest where
the plaza in front of the building kind
of being this opening in the forest but
also in the future I'm gonna have to
transition into a different area there
so this does help to get a tree line in
between different areas
so yeah that's basically how it works it
also helps to raise the restaurant
against the backdrop a little bit
because the restaurant is placed on a
hill and quite a bit higher than the
path in front of it which does give it a
bit of forced perspective to make it
look like a somewhat large restaurant
because it is quite a small building and
the plaza in front of it is actually
lowered a bit and lower than the rest of
the pots in the park to make it look
that little bit further away and a
little bit like it's sitting on the
larger rock than it really is this is
just a very quick look at what this
thing looks like right now it's not that
much I was kind of hoping to get more
stuff done in this episode but well
lately I've just been strolling quite a
bit things have been taking a bit longer
than I expected which isn't necessarily
an issue as long as I can still push it
before of where three comes around and
it's been nice to work on it so far
anyway so that doesn't really matter
but I am kind of behind schedule so that
serves something to note here and I've
also started work on the new part of the
park which actually took a fair amount
of time it won't be included in any of
the time lapses just the simple station
for the monorail which I'm working on
right now which I'll continue work on in
the next episode and that should be
parts of the finalizing of the German
area the German area is quite simple and
it's supposed to be like an area that
could be very small theme park just in
it's very starting phase in the way that
it's laid out so I do want it to be
quite closed and have only one or two
entrances into different parts of the
park and this is more or less the layout
of the German area a bit of work that I
still need to do is on the monorail
station and adding some buildings on the
side here with some kind of connection
into what it's going to be the Dutch
area and something along the ring that I
have over here which I'm not really sure
what I'm actually gonna do with it
same goes for this little area which may
very well become a nice entrance into
the Scandinavian kind of earlier which I
still have to figure out over here and
obviously this ride and all the scenery
around it's basically still needs to be
finished so yeah that stuff that you'll
see me doing and then in the next
episode which is going to be well quite
a bit messy since it is like all over
the place and no
really any kind of particular thing that
I'm working on as I did in this episode
which pretty much the entire focal point
is the restaurant itself but I just have
to get to fixing some of the smaller
things around this area there's also a
bit of like off-screen stuff that I want
to get into like actually making the
border of the park bit more neat and
tweaking some things here in there so
you'll see me do that as well also this
station is still a work in progress so
do you want to return to that as well
anyway that's it for today so thank you
guys for watching and I hope to see you
guys next time